Northern Ireland related terrorism has
not decreased that severe since 2009
today we've seen another example of the
intent dissident republicans have as
they attempted to murder police officers
and army personnel in County Fermanagh
they are reckless and indiscriminate on
this morning's attack had the potential
to kill anyone
in the immediate vicinity I am of the
firm belief it was a deliberate attempt
to lure place and army bomb disposal
colleagues into the area to murder them
at around 10:35 a.m. an explosion was
reported in the area of the Cavan Road
at its junction with the Walker Bridge
Road thankfully there were no reports of
any injuries and an investigation is now
underway to establish the exact cause of
the explosion we had received a report
that a suspect device had been left in
the area off wattle bridge on Saturday
evening the area was secured by police
and a full clearance operation began on
Sunday morning however this morning's
explosion deado care those who Meade
transported under ployed this device
should explain their actions to the
people of county fermanagh and/or than
ireland they bring nothing to society
they showed no regard when they entered
a public road and a public space to
create nothing other than inconvenience
and disruption to the local community on
attempt to murder public servants I wish
to acknowledge and command the bravery
and commitment of those officers and
army personnel at the scene of this
attack I would also like to thank the
community for their ongoing patience on
cooperation we must ensure their safety
so the area around the scene will remain
closed for some time yet until our
investigation and there are people
within our community who knew who did
this my message to them today is simple
please step forward
do the right thing and provide the
information to
police that will allow us to bring the
perpetrators before the courts